here we go and we play against the
Grateful Dead yep let's see what the
dead are doing yeah the sloth defense
yeah that's not the most lively as of
openings but still not know dad okay so
i'm getting the bishop pair which i
always appreciate to get okay so how do
we play this I don't really know I think
c5 is possible Quincy 7 might be an
answer though yeah maybe maybe still
some slowish moves see what he's doing I
can play c5 whenever I want actually hmm
okay I wonder about f4 and this position
system move f4 going for a big clamp in
the center this is some a bit comparable
to how to par love played this in his in
this infamous match in in lista 2006 and
scrum like he had ideas like that in
this in this line or not this precise
position but this fo ideas he played
more than once with good success
the usual problem with those quick
aphasia is exactly this this counter
counter blow in the center okay so how
do we play this I think I probably just
take me six trying to try to claim small
advantage in the end game not sure this
is really possible but i'm going to try
okay cd5 he can actually also take on
deform hmm interesting and dc5 he can
take on c4 if he likes with the night I
came he's definitely i'll write him
let's take their CD form do I have okay
it doesn't matter he didn't play it
hmm Kim interesting let's do it like
that just cover see for trying to play
against this somewhat awkwardly placed
night on b6 of course my position is not
without its problems I'm not I don't
even think that I'm better or anything
but the disposition that white has has
some potential if i get my pieces
coordinated due to the pair of bishops
should have three king of two i just
need a couple of moves to get get things
sorted in a way just pre-empting we
should be form is 94 hmm i didn't think
about that move
that's very awkward actually very
awkward brooksie 294 ma'am now he has
rupee aid hmm
yeah Luke see one that wasn't a very
successful idea
yes Bishop e3 for the draw if he wants
but that's really very unambitious black
is Sam probably fine Wow then I did not
expect at all okay rook e8 maybe okay
yes yeah the day ruki eight is good
that's interesting now that was
interestingly played if he goes ruki
eight now this justice make quite some
sense in fact okay hmm 49 f5
Jeremy texty form I don't like to take
that but it's difficult not to of course
is his night is potentially much better
than my bishop
Jim
Jim not taking that is difficult really
I do I don't think I'm in serious
trouble actually I think I can go with G
for this kind of thing yep may I can do
this it's not it's not doing that much
however I think let's see look everyone
who gave three or something it doesn't
really threaten much
and he's his slightly better it's
slightly better can even go rook e8 him
what taking a rookie aged something like
that case he's out for king of seven
probably yeah my rook is not very active
well I interesting yeah I played it
played an interesting way not how I
expected not bad at all
my ideas rook age to Roxy too I think I
should be okay after the Rope trade okay
hi my changes Jack Jack cause I mean I
can never hope to ever do something here
but he can shuffle forever in this
position with justification it's not
just a dry okay I'm I do aim at a clown
i can probably try on time but this is
really ridiculous after this game I was
so never ever better so I played it I
really played it badly and gave him a
good position down let's see maybe this
really wasn't a good idea so I took
their yeah he could have taken
non-default also what's interesting yeah
this I don't know yeah the next couple
of moves are probably the reason for my
trouble I mean okay what I did before
wasn't brilliant but probably not
leading to trouble but this I wanted to
go here but 94 is really awkward the
computer actually prefers that to my
move and gives 94 is clearly better for
black yeah I have to take and this is
this is not looking good night comes
here comes here wow that's really
terrible yeah I got a bad game okay TM
94 just wins oh-hoo-hoo-hoo night or
just wins yeah yeah of course me Knight
takes e4 takes you one chick haha oh wow
what a crappy game that was really bad
yeah and what he did is leading to an
okay position but nothing that Wow
computer wants to play rook e1 and gives
widen advantage this is just a joke
right why why should I can't how can
wide be better in this position with
this this Bishop that's very tough to
believe okay well you cannot go look I
cannot go King f8 to prevent rupee seven
I see the point I get to e7 hmm okay
yeah that's definitely better than the
game yeah i think i think what i did in
the game should be enough to 22
summerholt i mean i'm not having much
fun here but i think it's chan chan yeah
okay this is a draw the only thing that
you can argue for is that I have this
wrong porn there with my bishop but this
is not enough to win the game he doesn't
have a second weakness that he can
create somewhere so I'm okay him yeah
very lucky draw in this game actually I
should have lost that one yet many
chances to to put me away okay thanks
for watching